now shin fan made history recently uh
when taking um the most votes and the
most seats in northern ireland's
elections but the assembly is still
deadlocked as the dup demands changes to
the protocol and the uk government
rounds with the european union but the
non-sectarian alliance party was one of
the biggest winners too they more than
doubled their seats with a big jump in
votes especially among young people
possibly pointing to a different future
for northern irish politics well the
party says the assembly must restart and
they want to overhaul the entire power
sharing system
so let's speak now to the alliance
leader naomi long who is live in belfast
for us this morning thank you very much
for being with us um you did very well
in the recent assembly elections and i
just want to start by talking a little
bit about what the alliance party stands
for uh what is it that you're about and
what in particular is your stance on the
good friday agreement
well thank you sophia we have been
perfect supporters of the good friday
agreement because from our inception 51
years ago we were committed to power
sharing and devolution locally as the
best way to provide a stable future for
the people of northern ireland to allow
people to self-govern um and to create a
society which was egalitarian unfair
because that was not the case prior to
that point and unfortunately it's still
not the case now
alliance would describe itself um as a
liberal and progressive party but also
we are a pragmatic party and very keen
um to be able to continue to work to
deliver improvements for people's lives
which is why the assembly is so
important
at the same time you want to see
non-sectarian
power sharing which feels like it could
be quite ambitious do you think it is
really achievable
well i think the alternative is the stop
go assembly that we have seen over the
last five years where for the majority
of the time we haven't had functioning
devolution i don't believe that's
sustainable people in northern ireland
are facing a cost of living crisis
they're concerned about the state of our
health service which is some of the
longest waiting lists in the uk and what
they want is government to deliver
change and to try to assist them with
those issues and instead what they get
is government which is held to ransom
sometimes by shin fan sometimes by the
dup and a cycle of crisis and collapse
and the only way we can stop that
happening is to remove the vetoes that
those parties currently are able to
exercise over the institutions and allow
all votes in the assembly to account for
the same amount because currently my
vote doesn't count for the same amount
as other colleagues because i won't
designate as unionist or nationalist and
so we need to deal with this fundamental
issue the good friday agreement provided
us with a means of managing division in
northern ireland but society has changed
as the good friday agreement intended it
would in the last 24 years and so we now
need to be open to changing the
mechanisms and structures not the
principles of par sharing not the idea
that we have to share this place
together and work together in order to
deliver
but actually the mechanisms that are
there which currently are making the
institutions more unstable and that's
what we would like to see happen in
order that when we come to these
difficult issues whether it's the
protocol or or whether it's something
else because there is always something
else that we're able to work through
that rather than stop government until
it's resolved
you're talking about the sort of
stop-start nature of government and
schinofine and the dep being able to
hold northern ireland to ransom
do you think that is what the dep is
currently doing then holding northern
ireland to ransom by refusing to enter
power sharing because of their concerns
over the protocol or do you have a bit
more sympathy with their position
well i understand
their position i understand their lack
of trust in the uk government because i
think at times the uk government have
used northern ireland as
a bit of a play thing when it comes to
maintaining a grievance with europe they
believe that for them electorally for
the conservatives in england this is a
positive and so they're willing to
continue to have this constant grievance
with the european union and northern
ireland is i suppose a useful lever for
them but it's very damaging for
community relations and for good
governance in northern ireland and so i
do understand why the dup um lack trust
and promises made by the uk government
but undoubtedly they're holding the
people of northern ireland to ransom i
mean jeffrey donaldson himself has said
that he is using the position of being
able to prevent government as leverage
over the uk government so i mean there's
no question about that and they've been
openly admitting it my problem is that
it also holds the rest of us to ransom
who want to get back to work who want to
start delivering for the people who
elected us only two weeks ago and who
believe that there are parts that we
have within the assembly that can
address the very immediate problems of
fuel costs of the cost of food and
the cost of living
in northern ireland and can start to
deal with reform of our health service
which is urgent particularly post
pandemic and yet at the same time we can
negotiate around how the protocol could
be improved because i think all parties
agree um that certain changes would be
beneficial to northern ireland
businesses
so what do you think needs to change
about the protocol then
well from our perspective we are
pragmatic about the protocol it is
brexit that has ultimately caused the
instability in northern ireland as we
knew it would
the whole purpose of the good friday
agreement was to diminish the importance
of border border issues um and to make
northern ireland function in a fairer
way and unfortunately brexit put borders
and border friction uh back on the
agenda and that is very difficult for
the very delicate ecology of northern
ireland um to deal with
the protocol was an attempt albeit i
would say a rather um a rather heavy
haunted attempt to deal with those
border frictions and to ensure that
there was still free flow across the
border um on the island of ireland and
no hard border established but it did in
the end lead to
an additional level of friction in the
rhc and i understand that for unionists
um that is a very difficult situation
albeit for us it was an inevitability
and a consequence of brexit what we need
to do now is build trust with the
european union we're asking them
essentially um to devolve the protection
of the single market to
to the uk to allow us to have a green
channel for goods coming from gb to
northern ireland that won't go any
further but for them to do that they
need to trust the uk government will do
what it says it's going to do and of
course the history of the protocol is
that they haven't done that they've
taken unilateral action um and they've
failed to keep the agreement that they
negotiated and signed so we were very
clear when we met with the prime
minister earlier this week that what we
now need is for
negotiation between the uk and the eu to
be taken seriously by the uk government
for them to live up to the deals that
they make um and to work to build trust
rather than take unilateral action which
will undermine that because in doing so
we can minimize the impact of the
protocol on businesses both in gb and in
northern ireland but still allow
northern ireland to have the advantage
that it has which is free and unfettered
access both into the eu single market
for goods and into the uk single market
for goods and we need to exploit that in
order to grow our economy in northern
ireland i guess what the uk government
would argue is that yes they signed up
to the protocol but they didn't envisage
a situation where the eu would in their
view implement it in a heavy-handed way
so effectively assuming that goods are
going to be going on to the eu rather
than staying in northern ireland do you
have any sympathy with that position
from the uk government
none whatsoever because before they
signed the protocol there is evidence
that was presented to both the prime
minister um and indeed to lord frost
which said i'd very clearly what the
implications of the protocol would be um
you cannot negotiate a daily see what
that deal is going to do sign up to that
deal sell it as a good deal which is how
the prime minister fought the elections
let's remember um and then say that you
didn't fully understand what you'd
signed up to i mean that is just an
admission of failure on behalf of the
government
i think the presumption has always been
that the uk will behave in an
exceptional manner and will be allowed
to do so and unfortunately when we were
part of the european union we set the
rules for third countries and now we are
a third country we need to learn to live
by those rules and it seems to be
something that the government struggles
with i think most people will understand
this is a very simple thing when you
make an agreement and when you give your
word to do something you ought to be at
least prepared to do that thing before
you do so
and i think when you don't people will
then trust you less and less on every
subsequent occasion when you're asked to
give your word on something what we now
need is to break that cycle and actually
get the uk government to deal with the
eu who are still despite everything
willing to have these discussions and
willing to try to accommodate what is in
the best interest of northern ireland
and i think if we can get to a point
where the uk government and the eu can
set aside whatever issues they have
build that trust and get us a set of um
protocols in place that will allow good
governance because remember we need for
businesses sake political stability but
also stability in terms of the
arrangements going forward thank you uh
very much naomi long there of the
alliance party thank you for being on
the programme today